I am Alan Saucon and I'm currently
sitting with the infamous Nik Jimenez
yeah
Nik is awesome definitely one of my best
friends such an awesome guy he's got a
background linguistics philosophy
computer science Google robotics he's
all over the place he's crushing it and
we have really great conversation
because we're both the self-proclaimed
polymaths and we're aiming to have a
conversation about nuance in politics
today yeah this is gonna be great this
is gonna be a good one so we'll just
jump right into it and the first thing
we want to talk about is the importance
of free thinking and I you know me I
went from being the president of the
teenage Republicans Club in my high
school to being very very liberal in San
Francisco and I have not found myself
being a moderate like just right in the
middle free thinking and I found it to
be a great way to be able to talk to
people on both sides of the political
spectrum and kind of grab ideas from
both sides what do you think about that
and the importance of everything yeah I
mean I think it's important to say that
like free thinking is a value that I
think more people should have whether
they happen to find themselves on the
left on the right somewhere in the
middle somewhere anywhere on the like
libertarian to authoritarian spectrum
that like people don't see a label and
say I must believe everything that it
says because the while maybe not every
possible political persuasion has valid
points I think at minimum there's
something to learn from all of them and
they do all have valid places yes and
that's the key that there is something
to learn from all these different
perspectives how did the person finally
come to this perspective that they have
what was their life journey that brought
them to this point and the only way to
really be able to understand that is by
actually asking them deep questions and
caring about them and where
came from and how they feel the way they
do and so a really fun thing that we
were just talking about with Junoon last
night on simulation was the idea of if
you find yourself frequently talking to
one demographic of people just have some
fun go to the other demographic of
people and just stay open-minded and
just ask questions and yeah I mean there
are so many different people who have
lived through like drastically different
governments drastically different like
sorts of political systems especially
like people who lived through the former
Soviet Union like they have different
perspectives because their life
experience is so different and whether
or not you like totally agree with that
like there's a lot to learn from them
exactly exactly
I remember having conversations with my
mom and uncle about what some of the
nuances were in Soviet Union and there
were actually some things that they were
like no no no really bad and there were
and they were like some things like hey
I'd like some of the programs were
actually really interesting yeah yeah I
mean helping mothers nurture kid yeah I
was gonna spell I mean I think one of
the things Jeannie was talking about
last night was like that you have
capitalism and you have socialism a sort
of extreme opposites and at their
extremes they both have like serious
walls like if you appear capitalism you
don't have fire departments that's
technically a socialist idea who's going
to yeah private fire fire stations and
police stations and yeah roads who's
gonna privately build roads and highways
yeah nobody nobody and like at the other
extreme end you have socialism and
there's like no incentive to innovate
and like somewhere in the middle is the
happy the happy spot and that's why we
have these nuanced political
conversations to find something good
stuff and socialism capitalism
maybe innovate with some new ideas that
haven't been discussed in either one of
them and get to this sort of future that
we want to build exactly yes so we also
want to talk about a little bit of like
this idea of being okay with not knowing
an answer to something and kind of the
the importance of being humble with
saying I don't know but I'm gonna
to research so I can try and get to an
answer yeah yep and I mean I think one
of the tough things because I think it's
such a like such an important concept in
the sciences where you say until you
have proven something you don't know it
but like in politics and economics and
some of these like broader social
sciences like there's not many
laboratories I can smash atoms and get
hundreds of thousands of data points
trying to get hundreds of thousands of
data points on tax policy is fool's
errand yes it's not gonna happen yes
well we can't it's very difficult to and
when we do it will make our analysis so
much better Oh certainly
but it's going to take orders of
magnitude longer yes yes it's so much
more subjective than science yeah and
you end like you also get into more like
ethical quandary yes when you're trying
to do something it's really important to
get it right because it affects so many
people
so and that you have to make like you
have to make decisions with partial
information and say maybe I don't know
what the best answer is but from the
limited set of information I have here
are some of the ideas here's some of the
interpretations of that data and here's
some of the ways that we can do it yeah
and here's why we believe we should do
it this way yeah and I think there's
especially with such a limited data
several valid perspectives on most like
approaches to things so let's jump into
our next topic and we'll the same topic
political nuance but we're actually
gonna give examples now yeah and so
here's a really good example that I was
just talking to Nick about a little bit
that I think is a really good way to
understand what we're talking about so
let's take immigration for example if we
take a binary understanding of where we
stand on immigration I mean a for
immigration or against immigration and
that's the end of the conversation we're
gonna miss out on all of the really
interesting nuance that when you're able
to actually have a discussion with
someone around
how do you think about this point about
it or that point and so one of the
examples that we were talking about is
maybe potentially not being so in favor
of h-1b visas in a way that they tie the
employer to the corporation or maybe not
wanting to deport people that are here
illegally and now when we spend our
resources on that or maybe not wanting
to allow in refugees that have
backgrounds that are a little bit
scheduled you need to do better
background analysis but still bring
people and because of humanity so that
kind of nuance that's like three sub
points around immigration that will get
us to much better conversation yeah I
mean I think it's important this is
another great example where both
extremes are actually pretty terrible
you know like if you let literally
anybody into the country I think you can
obviously imagine like why that might
fail and you might like not have stable
population you might do a lot of things
if you let literally nobody in the US
has a below replacement rate birth rate
yes which means eventually your
population is going to do this and human
capital super important yes or burden we
want to bring innovators from around the
world to the u.s. actly there's so many
other ones here let's keep and I mean I
think I would argue like getting more of
those perspectives like yeah you want to
build you want to build apps that
effective billion people
you can't just target Americans because
there's not a billion of them like you
get somebody who grew up in India you
get somebody who grew up in China and
they actually have a they can help you
build that broader perspective and
realize oh if we do this low bandwidth
environments we're gonna have a terrible
experience and they won't use it and
there's and there's things like in India
if you talk to someone you'll learn
about Paytm
and if you talk to someone in China you
might learn more about Alibaba and you
might really get a more well-rounded
perspective about maybe mobile payments
as well as Commerce and distribution of
goods and boom all of a sudden you
become better well-known to what of how
three billion other people well that's
that's an order of made through more
than the US oh yeah
boom yeah just like that so that so this
is really important so let's give
another example of let's talk about
taxes yep so we can talk a lot about
corporations less taxes so that they can
potentially provide more to our economy
more jobs more innovation etc and we can
also talk about the importance of
providing social programs for people
that are physically or mentally unable
to do so for themselves and and have a
really kind of strict way of
understanding who's like taking
advantage of the system or not yeah so
again we're talking about multiple
levels of nuance and taxes not just for
and fate for high taxes are for low
taxes so again why is this so important
yeah I mean I think like taxes are so
often when you talk to people about
taxes you really get like at the heart
about what they believe government is
supposed to be yes like you have on sort
of the very libertarian you have I think
Penn Jillette is the person I most
associate with this idea but like if you
would not use a gun to accomplish a
mission to accomplish a goal you should
not do it with tax money
mm-hmm a very limited narrow view of
what government should do you mean
example of that quick I'm so like for
example I mean like eminent domain or
like helping or providing health care
for people if you wouldn't use a gun to
provide health care you shouldn't use it
tax money would be a like fairly strong
libertarian view on that use of guns
health care so the idea is that a
government the government has a monopoly
on violence you don't pay your taxes oh
what happens to you Oh somebody with a
gun comes and takes away your freedom
so in some sense so goes the argument if
you if you would not do something with
the gun
and detain someone for not doing you
shouldn't do that's me so for example I
want police and fire trucks and roads so
that's an important thing to include in
taxes but maybe healthcare is not so
much yeah I don't I think different
people draw that line in different
places okay but like certainly the it's
like it's about the monopoly on violence
okay and then we were researching the
Laffer curve which we thought was really
interesting
to share with everyone the idea that at
some point along this curve and we don't
know exactly if it looks like they're
just a normal bell curve or how it's
exactly shaped but there's some sweet
spot in terms of the tax rate that can
have to foster massive amounts of
innovation and we are we're we weren't
having a discussion we think it's
somewhere around maybe thirty to fifty
percent would be an ideal sort of way to
say here's what we need for roads and
yeah we some stuff and here's what we
need for for you to be able to innovate
as well yeah I mean I think it's a cool
idea like in the u.s. so much in the
dialogue is raise taxes lower taxes but
it's more complicated than that like
what is your net tax rate if it's really
low lowering taxes is not a good idea
your government is going to go into
massive debt which is some of the effect
that we see happening right now but if
your tax rates are high you really
shouldn't be raising them because you're
gonna start stifling innovation and
decreasing that incentive to be
successful yeah so you have this access
of at some point raising raising taxes
keeps raising government revenue until
it starts stifling innovation so and
that's where you get this curve laughter
curve
LAF fer look it up check it out it's
epic all right in let's jump into the
last sort of part of nuanced politics
which is this like open-mindedness and
so I like to use myself as the example
here by explaining in a way that I talk
about AI a lot and I talk about AI from
like a very 10,000 foot perspective
looking downward on it and Nick might
come up to me one day and he might say
something like Alan maybe you're not
you've got this 10,000 foot view pretty
good but there are some nuance to your
understanding of how AI works yep that
is you're not quite there yet and here's
some content for you to look up and
research in order for you to become
better and better understanding oh yeah
and if you do that to me
usually people respond in one of two
ways the first way is something like
Nick thanks for coming and telling me
that I really
appreciate it you're a mean the help
make me better and I'm gonna take the
content that you recommended and I'm
gonna go and research it this week and
understand it better and I'm gonna email
you at the end of the week with a kind
of main points that I took away from it
and we'll have another discussion about
and there's that view and then there's
the view of where I might take offense
to what you said and be like hey you
think I don't know about nuance and AI
and if I get that stifles ya really
important conversation that should be
happening oh yeah absolutely I think
like it's important to recognize these
sort of limits and where this becomes a
dissing allergy but like the idea of
there's so much more than you commonly
hear that's important detail to really
understand what's going on in politics
and economics and society that like
getting some of those ideas and no
matter how no matter where you go from
there like looking into them reading
about it learning and then sort of
intellectually chewing on it is a
valuable exercise for a bit almost
anybody and then sometimes people will
come up to you and try and help you find
more of this content so that you can
intellectually chew on it and
experientially chew on it a little more
yeah
but there's always the problem that oh
that person didn't did tell it to me in
a way that was emotionally intelligent a
representative of Who I am how I feel
but then the other person needs to
challenge themselves to not be so soft
and try and take a little bit of good
critique into as wisdom that they should
vote on yeah that person said it for a
reason I should go look it up more yeah
I mean I think it's important to meet
people in the middle like there should
that be this good like edifying intent
that you really want to help the person
I think you're not trying to you know
make money from them or scare them more
like motivate them to do something that
you want whether you're really trying to
help them but also that the other person
is like okay so I know what they're
trying to do I know they're time to like
teach me about something and actually
like look into it exactly
so we covered a bunch of topics and
nuanced politics and this is a
free-thinking is so important
open-mindedness is so important really
thinking about how to not
the binary sort of perspective on issues
but love the nuance yeah I asked people
about the nuance more I'm going to be
like gentle and not like bring up that
defensive wall exactly practice I'm not
bringing up the defensive wall so
important we're gonna have much more of
these conversations with Nick makes a
great mind to play intellectual tennis
with I love you so much thank you for
having this conversation will do it
again very soon
cheers Island I love it